welcome back to age 20. in this
section you want to look at light what
is it and how does it propagate in this
video specifically i give you a little
bit of a preview of 802
and i don't do this in a very
pedagogical way i just give you some
information okay
so if we in the study 802 we'll see
maxwell equations are being developed in
there if we look at maxwell equations
for electric in the magnetic field e and
b in vacuum we can rewrite the maximum
equations and we find wave equations
the solutions of the wave equations as a
name tells you are waves
so what we are looking at here is you
want to describe the propagation of
electric and magnetic fields in vacuum
in this situation this is
maybe at some
time t equals zero we have an electric
field in this point p here and a
magnetic field electric field points
into the y direction the magnetic field
into the v direction and what's what
those equations now describe is how the
wave propagates in space and in time
and it you know you can already
you know tell from the name wave
equation
solutions of this equation this
differential equations are sines and
cosines
so one solution here is
e y equal to e naught times cosine
kx minus omega t
okay
you find then that the speed in which
the wave propagates
you pick one
uh
peak of a wave and you see how it
propagates one point of the variance
here propagate the speed in which it
propagates is the speed of light c
and you can find c here through those
constants
in those
in the next equation in the wave
equations
y and c is one over square root epsilon
naught
the permittivity and the permeability
um
the product of the two gives you the
speed of light
great so if you look at this some more
um and connect to the vapor maxwell
equation the lawrence force
um
again as a reminder for those who had
had 802 already
the force on the charged particle and
electric magnetic field is given by
q times e plus q times v cross b
if you have two charges the force
between those two charges is the product
of the two divided by r square um times
one over four pi epsilon naught again
this very same constant
and the force between two wires
with currents um current i1 and current
i2
is equal the product of the two currents
divided by r times l the length of the
of the wires
um times mu naught over two pi so this
is fantastic because now you can
calculate the speed of light by just
measuring the forces between charges and
currents and wires
centers
all right
the value of c is also very interesting
it's large very large
three times ten to the eighth meters per
second to just let this sink in you know
we as humans we move with a few meters
per second
light travels
with
you know a few minutes a few nanoseconds
it is needed for light to travel about
one meter it takes us one second
okay um
let's stop the video here the next thing
i want to do
is an exercise i want to have you play
with this differential equations and
there's a solution of the differential
equation
but the challenge or the exercise is to
show
that if you have a function which you
can write as
f naught which is an arbitrary function
which is a function of x minus c t
those functions
regardless in how they look like are
solutions of this differential equation
note that i replaced our constant
epsilon naught and u naught now with one
over z squared
so f naught can really be an arbitrary
function uh you need to be able to build
the derivative so okay
so i do this function here
as a function of x for some time equal
to zero okay and then i drew
the same function uh for time
t equal one
and so you can from this picture see
that the delta x over delta t is minus c
in this case so my
function my wave is moving with the
speed of light in minus direction
all right so i want you to show that
this
kind of equation
um
obviously the wave equation
okay so i would like you to do this and
stop the video i'll show you the
solution next
so the way to approach it is simply
applying the chain rule and that might
be something you want to remind yourself
of
so if i do this
i define this little helper function
here
u is equal x minus c t
um this makes our function a function of
u which is itself a function of x and t
so if i build the derivative with x i
have this df of u
u times
the u
dx
okay so the second derivative
there's a product here i have to take
care of so i find that these d is the
second derivative of f
of f of u
here
times the u dx squared
and then i have to add
the fdu times second derivative of u1
okay
this follows very similar for the
derivative of t
and then i can investigate what we find
so my du x
is equal to one right
d u d x will be the derivative of x
minus d t
this x i find one i do the same with t i
find minus c
okay i will use this
second derivatives of u
on x and t are all zero
okay if i put this in now in my equation
i find second derivative of f
with u
is uh of 1 minus
c
sorry 1 minus 1 over c square times c
square
is equal to 0
and since this is always 0
we have just proven
that
any sort of function which i can build
the derivative of
which is of the form
sorry which is of the form
x minus ct
solves the vape equation